in the last few videos we explore in a
situation where the aggregate demand
curve shifted to the right and that
caused inflation and that's actually
called demand pull inflation what I want
to do in this video is study situation
where the aggregate the short-run
aggregate supply curve shifts to the
left and that causes inflation and
that's called cost-push inflation cost
cost push inflation cost push inflation
so let's just start off with our
standard our standard graph so this is
aggregate prices this is real aggregate
productivity real GDP right over here
and I'm gonna focus things on the
short-run aggregate demand right over
here that is our aggregate demand curve
and then our aggregate supply aggregate
supply in the short-run this is what
we're gonna focus on might look
something like that
so this is aggregate supply in the
short-run and this is our current level
this is our current level of prices and
the reason why I draw aggregate supply
in the short-run having this kind of
this curve that keeps getting steeper
and steeper if you think in algebraic
terms the slope gets larger and larger
as you go to the right one way to think
about it if the real GDP is down here
maybe performing well below its
potential there's a lot of excess
capacity in the economy excess labor
capacity acts excess factory capacity
and then if you so if you want more
productivity out of that economy people
aren't going to demand much more prices
won't have to go up more there's a lot
of slack in the economy well as GDP gets
higher and higher maybe even going
beyond its potential starts to get
overheated in order for people to get to
very very high levels of utilization or
essentially get more people to enter
into the labor market or work longer
hours work overtime the prices are
essentially going to have to go up so
over here for an increment for some
increment in GDP prices don't have to go
up so much so you have a lower slope
then say over here for that same
increment in GDP prices have to go up
dramatically now with that out of the
way let's think about what would happen
if the aggregate supply curve were to
shift to the left and we could also
think about why would it shift to the
left
so let's first just shift it to the left
so let's just shift it to the left it
might look something like that
so at any given point I just tried to
shift
to the left and you see a new aggregate
you see a new equilibrium price and
equilibrium GDP this was the old
equilibrium price and the old
equilibrium real GDP this is the new
equilibrium price and the new
equilibrium real GDP and you see you
definitely had inflation price went up
but this is worse than ourn depending on
how you view things but in general this
is worse than the demand pull inflation
because at least with the demand pull
inflation we saw that over here you had
inflation happening but GDP real GDP
increased even more it started to get
overheated but over here you have the
other way around prices went up prices
went up but your gdp actually contracts
and this is a situation that you might
you might have heard the firt word
before this is stagflation inflation
with stagnation so this is stag
stagflation and there's two very notable
examples of this in recent US history in
1973 you had the night the Arab oil
embargo it was apparently due and to
respond to respond to us support of
Israel in the Yom Kippur War so you had
the 1973 oil embargo embargo and in 1979
1979 you have your revolution in Iran
Iran was a major oil producer then
continues to be but it was even more
significant in 1979 and so during all
the chaos during the revolution Iran's
oil productivity dropped dramatically
and so you also had so you had an oil
crisis and the reason why oil crises
would shift the cost would shift would
shift the curve to the left oil crisis
so in both of these situations the
supply of oil drops dramatically and so
if the supply of oil and this is kind of
a might a micro phenomenon if the supply
of something drops dramatically the
price the price of that thing is going
to go up dramatically
and the 70s oil was even a bigger part
of the US economy than it is now you
probably remember if you were around in
the 70s very very large cars that had
very bad gas mileage and other uses of
oil were also much much less efficient
in the 1970s so it was a big input into
the US economy and if all of a sudden
major input if a major inputs price
start it becomes much much more
expensive then for you could view it one
of two ways for a given level of
productivity people will suppliers will
want to charge more if you want me to
deliver this to your house if you want
me to run your truck so for a given
level of productivity suppliers would
charge more so you could view it like
that or you could view at at a given at
a given level of price suppliers will
want to produce less so at a given price
so let's say this price right over here
a supplier would want to produce less
because they're not getting as much real
profit and so you could view it as a
shift to the left or you could even view
it if you say at a given level of
productivity if you want me to produce
that level you're gonna have to pay me
more to offset my price increases so you
could also view it as a shift up either
one but we'll think of it as a shift
left in this context and so you see this
does describe what happened to during
these two oil crises in the 1970s
because of this increase in the price of
oil at any given price suppliers were
willing to supply left a grits short-run
aggregate supply shifts to the left
you have the inflation and you also have
the stagnation real GDP goes down